Mario Torre atlanta-based mm-hmm well
part of Atlanta Decatur dictator
Oh are you safe everywhere Decatur yeah
okay I don't like how you thought about
in my home yes my house is the most
dangerous spot why you might think your
house is a little dangerous my kids and
a dog it's horribly some of the words
that's the worst of all right look out
dog you don't woman nope I got dogs man
get them I got a dhobi right there shut
the front door the best breed of dollars
you can buy but I kill you you said you
said doesn't the real gun I didn't even
know you had stop haven't you yes we
were here our souls scrolled through
pictures man that's me and Roxy when she
first came home oh good double where we
were so you got boy got a boy do you
feel like he has he adapted your
personality house
no no he's scared for me really well you
must have threatened him it's a toys
it's the one yeah that's it out now a
better situation say man just got
engaged
yeah congratulate off she's in the
service man Wow
yeah so it was very organized about okay
yeah gonna you know this army a dog
three kids
oh yeah you got lucky what are you
walking on the line huh
walking on a straight line I'll tell you
so comedy is an outlet is it what and
I'll let oh my god me wait you leave the
house Reggie's on the same web you know
definitely keeps me going you know
there's some motivation I've got a
family and depend on you so I keep going
I love that Maris and I like the fact
that you dig into your life if anything
off limits not allowed to gives its open
man reality is the funny so you can
basically dig into who you are
then why I do it pretty much exactly and
you're doing it man you're figuring it
out brother it's time for you to get to
the next level man walk on that stage
and do what you do best let's go I feel
a tomato
[Music]